سمعنا امبارح انه الاتحاد الفلسطيني ما
صوت لملف السعوديه لاستضافه كاس اسيا
وحاولنا نتواصل مع الاتحاد الفلسطيني
لنعرف شو اللي صار وتواصلنا معناه برايس
الاتحاد الفلسطيني وعضو اللجنه التنفيذيه
للاتحاد الاسيوي السيدات سوزان شلبيه
سوزان شلبي اكدت انه مندوب الاتحاد
الفلسطيني كان واقف مع المسؤولين
السعوديين في الخارج خارج قاعه التصويت
وكان على اساس انه ما في تصويت وفجاه
فوجئوا انه في تصويت فدخلوا امامهم 30
ثانيه للادلاء باصواتهم وعندما حاول انه
هو يشغل الجهاز ما اشتغل معه وظهرت نتيجه
وكانه الاتحاد الفلسطيني امتنع عن التصويت
للاتحاد السعودي وهو الابررب لحدث مع
الاتحاد التركماني ايضا حسب قولها جبريل
جوب رئيس الاتحاد الفلسطيني قال انه
مندوبنا اخطا بعمليه تصويت وكان فيه خطا
فني وهذا الامر الذي نتج عنه عدم تصويت
الاتحاد الفلسطيني لملف السعوديه